all dictators should be warned about
this the longer you stay there the more
isolated you get the more you'll only
hear from people who are flattering you
to tell you what you want I'm sure a lot
of the intelligent failures were people
telling them what he wanted to hear I
mean if you're an FSB agent if you said
to me if you sent a note a report back
to Moscow saying by the way a lot of
ukrainians actually probably will fight
for the country that would be the end of
your career and so I think Putin had
convinced himself there's also really
interesting element here he thought the
West Was decadent and have you noticed
how often he talks about gender and he
talks about same-sex marriage and he
talks about transgender you know there's
something really deeply weird there but
I think he he had convinced himself that
no I think the fact that he fixes on it
um you know who knows I mean I'm not
going to get into Putin psychology
because that would be like getting into
Hades